الحرس الثوري الايراني يعتقل
اجانب من بينهم السفير البريطاني
الروسي على القوانين التي تلزم
الشركات الخاصة بدعم الجهود
وزراء اسرائيل على حكومة لبنان
كبح جماح حزب الله. والا ستضطر
القذافي فيتضمن انسحاب جميع
الشخصيات التي تشكل طرفا في
الاسلام يرى ان لا حلول غير ما
طرحه. فهل يرى الليبيون ذلك?
الانتخابات الرئاسية بمشاركة
الجميع من دون اقصاء اي طرف
عن اي عروبة نتحدث يا سادة حل
الازمة الليبية. قدم سيف الاسلام
من داعم للقضية الفلسطينية. في
حين رفع جنود الجزائر علم فلسطين
المكتب السياسي لحركة حماس
اسماعيل هنية على طاولة واحدة في
تسريب المكالمة وبشدة. الجزائر
رمز للعروبة. في لقاء تاريخي
بايدن. بوتين وافق مبدئيا. لكنه
بعد الرجوع لمستشاريه وبعد اربعة
بوتين المكالمة بحجة ممارسة
رياضة الهوكي موسكو استنكرت
الذي وصفه بالانقلابي والدموي.
حاول نفي الاتهامات بحده وانهى
الحدود الاوكرانية عليه عقد قمة
في جنيف مع الرئيس الامريكي جو
الحرس الثوري يجري تجارب
الصواريخ الفضائية. الصين
وامريكا وروسيا في سباق احدث
الاسلحة. فهل يبدأ احدهم حربا
الجواسيس اخذوا عينات من الارض
في صحراء وسط ايران حيث كان
قادرة على اجبار على امداد الجيش
بالسلع وجعل موظفيهم يعملون
اسرائيل لفعل ذلك. على خلفية
اتهامهم بانشطة استخباراتية.
في كونها تحمل قمحا اوكرانيا
مسروقا. من جانبها انقرة اعلنت
البريطاني يحذران من التجسس
التجاري الصيني. القوات
وروسيا قادر على تتبع الاسلحة
التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت
واربعين دقيقة. وطلب منه ماكرون
تقليل قواته المحتشدة حينها على
واحدث سلاح للجيش الامريكي يعمل
البنتاجون على تطويره. بكين
ودبلوماسيون. ونقلت الوكالة عن
التليفزيون الرسمي ان هؤلاء
الاوكرانية تتراجع لمناطق اكثر
تحصينا في وبوتين يدعو قواته الى
لساعات اضافية لدعم حرب موسكو ضد
اوكرانيا هذه الاجراءات تضع
تعزيز الهجوم بعد الاستيلاء على
مدينة ليسيتشانسك. وافق البرلمان
محطة نووية محطة تسقط بيد الجيش
الروسي ويحولها الى قاعدة
روسيا في اقتصاد الحرب بعد خمسة
اشهر على بداية الحرب. رئيس
العسكرية في اوكرانيا. ومع هذا
القرار ستكون الحكومة الروسية
عسكرية. اوكرانيا تطالب تركيا
بالتحفظ على سفن روسية للتحقيق
في البلاد ومن دون اراقة دماء.
ويتضمن المقترح الاول اجراء
وباشراف وادارة جهة محايدة. اما
المقترح الثاني الذي قدمه
البلاد معتبرا انهما محاولة
اخيرة للخروج من الوضع المتأزم
زلينسكي وهو يستسلم حتى صار هذا
المقطع متداولا عالميا. اكبر
التقصي عن مزاعم سرقة الحبوب
الاوكرانية. مديرا الامريكي
الخلافات السياسية من الانتخابات
الرئاسية بشكل جماعي. سيف
احتياطي عملة اليوان مع بنك
التسويات الدولية الى جانب خمس
الرد الامريكي على بكين وموسكو.
سلاح حراري جديد بوجه الصين
المركزية في العالم استثمرت او
تفكر في الاستثمار في اليابان.
الصين تأمل ان تؤدي هذه التحركات
الى زعزعة مكان الدولار في
ماكرون يستمعون للحديث من غرفة
مجاورة ويشاركون معه بعد
الجزائر بعد سنوات من الخلاف.
خلال احتفالات بذكرى عيد
وبوتين قبل الحرب الاوكرانية.
واستمرت المكالمة حوالي خمس
القذافي مبادرة من مقترحين لما
وصفه بالحل السلمي للازمة في
خلال عرض عسكري بمناسبة عيد
الاستقلال. في غضون ذلك الرئيس
رأس الاولويات السياسية
والدبلوماسية وانعم بالجزائريين
الاسلحة الفرض صوتية. هذا السلاح
الحراري يعمل بالطاقة الشمسية
الاحداث والتطورات. قديروف ينشر
مقطعا ساخرا للرئيس الاوكراني
الجزائري لم يقف هناك وحسب فتح
ذراعيه واعلن فتح الحدود مع تونس
لجمع البيانات وتزويد البرية
بالاتصالات وتخفيف مشاكل الاقمار
الرئيس الجزائري تبون جمع الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس ورئيس
ما قبل الحرب. وثائقي فرنسي يعرض
تفاصيل مكالمة حادة بين ماكرون
ايام جاء الرد باشتعال الحرب
الاوكرانية. وكان مستشاروا
انهاء هيمنة وبدأت بخطة لمجموعة
دول بريكس لانشاء عملة احتياطي
الجزائرية ترى ان القضية
الفلسطينية قضية مبدأ يتربع على
استقلاله الستين ويا له من
احتفال للجزائريين. الوساطة
الملاحظات. بوتين وجه اتهاماته
للغرب ولنظام الحكم الاوكراني
المجنون لاجراء اول تجربة نووية
له منذ خمس سنوات. مخاوف كوريا
الجنوبية تتزايد بعد تعليمات
رئيسهم جاء ذلك بعد ساعات من نشر
ميلا. امريكا تتخوف ايضا من
تكثيف تطوير روسيا للاسلحة الفرض
ورغم ان تهديد ازالة الدولار
كعملة احتياطية في العالم الا ان
دول اخرى. وبحسب التقارير فان
خمسة وثمانين بالمائة من البنوك
قادر على حمل السلاح النووي
والذي اخطأ هدفه بحوالي عشرين
صوتية والسلاح الحراري الامريكي
عبارة عن بالونات حرارية تتعقب
واشنطن اغسطس الماضي باختبار
صاروخ تفوق سرعته سرعة الصوت
الصناعية. فهل يعد هذا السلاح
تهديدا خطيرا على بكين وموسكو?
عالمية في الوقت نفسه اعلن بنك
الشعب الصيني انه يقوم ببناء
لواشنطن اين هي منظوماتكم امام
ذات الفم النووي خاصتنا. اما
واشنطن طائرات اف خمسة وثلاثين
في بلاده ضمن المشتركة لمواجهة
الصين فتحارب بسلاح اخر اكثر
فاعلية وتتخذ خطوات جديدة نحو
استعراض العضلات النووية. سلاح
روسي جديد يدخل خط المواجهة
كييف تتراجع بينما تطلب اوكرانيا
المساعدات من تركيا فهل تساعدها?
تدمير منظومتين صاروخيتين
امريكيتين من طراز. موسكو تقول
بقدرات مرعبة. منظومة تورنيدو اس
تستطيع محو مساحة تعادل مائة
ملعب كرة قدم قدرتها تضاهي قوة
الاسلحة النووية راجمة الصواريخ
يونسوكيول عقد اجتماعا مع كبار
قادة الجيش وطالبهم بالرد بسرعة
خمسة وثلاثين الى سيول. فما
القصة? رئيس كوريا جنوبية
ودبلوماسيين اوروبيين بتهمة
التجسس. وروسيا تقر اقتصاد
جنون كيم لا يتوقف. الاوضاع
مشتعلة في الجزيرة الكورية
تهديدات كوريا الشمالية. فهل
يستطيع الامريكان ايقاف المجنون?
التجارة الدولية. فهل تنجح الصين
في معركتها ضد الدولار? هنا ياتي
عالية الدقة وتدعى بذات الفم
النووي. الدفاع الروسية تعلن
الروسية تستخدم موسكو خلال معركة
شرق اوكرانيا وتتميز بصواريخها
الازمة الليبية. فهل تستجيب له
الحكومة? وايران تحتجز سفراء
فرنسي لمكالمة بين بوتين وماكرون
قبل اندلاع حرب اوكرانيا لتضع
كله؟ كم يسرق من عيون اعدائه
بهذا الاجراء. ويرعب جارته
على القيام بها لتضع اسرائيل في
حالة رعب. والرئيس تبون يفتح
تحارب واشنطن بسلاح قد يسقطها
ارضا. فلمن ستكون الغلبة بعد هذا
سلاح الحديد. وروسيا ترد بسلاح
على الاراضي الاوكرانية. والصين
меня Раисель украл
الحرب. فماذا يعني اقتصاد الحرب?
بوتين يأمر قواته بمواصلة الهجوم
وصرامة على اي استفزاز يقوم به
مجنون جارتهم الشمالية حيث يستعد
جارته الجنوبية يصدر اوامره
للجيش وواشنطن ترسل طائرات اف
المجنون يستعد لاجراء تجارب
عسكرية بالصواريخ النووية ورئيس
ذراعيه لتونس. نجل العقيد
القذافي يظهر مجددا بحلول لانهاء
اوكرانيا. الجزائر تقوم بخطوة
تاريخية لم يجرؤ اي قائد عربي
командованием. Мы ее доказали
это? Конечно же
على الاخر لتندلع الحرب العالمية
الثالثة?
امريكا في موقف محرج. وصيد نووي
ثمين بيد الجيش الروسي في
الجنوبية لتضع جيشها على اهبة
الاستعداد. فماذا يحدث؟ تسريب
Капитуляцию всех сил я
перебиваю под украинским